[ __ ] myself I've shot it I'm sorry
before hey what's going on everybody
first we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot one it's the show with high
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Charlemagne to God
Sean hey what's up my brother you know
him from The Breakfast Club on power 105
his show uncommon sense live on mtv2 you
know and he's here to promote his new
book black privilege opportunity comes
to those who create it Charlemagne
welcome to the show
all factual no alternative facts were
spitting anything you said hey are you
with hot food I'm at the pins man I got
weird vows like like anything makes me
[ __ ] you're not I'm saying right but
it's not that I dislike hot food I just
know what it does my butthole lady and
I'm not like into burning buttholes well
are you ready to get it going
[Music]
so this first one is sriracha sriracha
is no big deal hmmmm no right on seven
million questions about The Breakfast
Club but I won't keep you all day so
I'll keep them to my most pressing well
so what do you think is the closest
you've ever been to getting punched in
the face during that interview uh Nellie
so everybody always looks at the real
hostile intense ones like Berman or
Fredro Starr with Nellie because I
actually actually believe nelio fight
you first time he came to America I told
him you cold out here right now Bryan by
really checking for pictures no mom he
was like you know we keep retainers for
people like you man which artist do you
think gives the best interviews right
now the old daughter's always that's
would definitely fragile in noria to the
top I love her got it - I like talking
about garlic sauce if you think about
awkward interviews is there one that
stands out I mean I think we've
interviewed amigos at least four or five
times I think we might only air one
because it's just like what are we
talking about whose reaction to being
donkey of the day surprised you the most
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton gave us
a sound bite that I use and wanted to
talk you today intros not Larry Clinton
said oh I'm a Democrat so being a donkey
is sort of a mixed blessing like that
was surprising
first of all what surprised me even go
to hell don't here today was that's
number one and she need to take offense
to it at all which celebrity hates you
the most if you had to guess if the talk
I'm black buy a lot of people my man got
me blocked on Twitter Odell Beckham jr.
chilli from TLC Ashanti Amy Schumer
really yeah it'd be like random ID are
felissa
good with good good group of people to
be luck fun absolutely
which rapper do you think is the best
chance of stealing your job rapper nine
[Music]
hmm not America go ahead I want to talk
to you about being a superhero fanatic
for a second because in addition to
having Wolverine tattooed on your right
arm you were able to star and write your
own Marvel comic absolutely emcees I
think used to be really influenced by
superhero and even like Method Man and
MF DOOM those sound like comic book
characters do you think that that's sort
of been washed away and if so do you
think that there's some other thing
that's bubbling up and filling that void
oh that's a good question but you don't
really have too many comic book
references you used to hear them all the
time all the time I think just because
people play the streets too close so all
of their material is coming from like
what's going on in the hood like back in
the data artists were like a lot more
creative so they were like literally
rapping about any and everything like
you hit kung fu references you hear
comic book references you hear like
great sitcom references now everything
is about to trap my regional comic books
in the trap all right so this next one
is all Yucatec Oh what the hell is that
only peanut on the table that's out
right here okay I want to talk to you
about your relationship with Kanye West
for a second because you guys have such
an interesting dynamic
on one hand you're really able to poke
that hornet's nest of his ego but on the
other hand you seem to have some of the
more honest discussions that I hear from
Kanye West yeah talking to him face to
face
have you seen a major change over the
last couple years because from the
outside looking in that's always the
topic of endless fascination you know
what is the reinvention the new persona
and Kanye West and what's the real Kanye
well have you seen the movie get out I
definitely think Kanye's in a sunken
place and I think that he's been in the
sunken place ever since he got with Kim
Kardashian that's why I called him
Carney Kardashian because if you think
about where Kanye was Kanye was almost
like an activist I give it was something
going on in the community you could
count on Kanye West to call it out and
then it's like over time he just got
real indiscreet touching their lives it
seems like and the only interest he
cared about was things that was going on
in the industry whether it was music and
no the Grammy showing artists the proper
respect whether it was fashion and you
know trying to break through in the
fashion industry as a black man he just
got farther and farther away from the
pavement so to speak I feel like you
know he's doing us a great disservice
because I feel like Kanye had one of
those real powerful voices man he had
one of those voices that cut through
talk everybody not just black people
I just white people everybody listens to
Kanye West and I feel like he could
really be using his voice for more than
just you know telling us to buy sneakers
someone to help you actually drink the
milk and coat your stomach so the milk
is you know the derry-o kind of cut the
heat a little bit but not you
Charlemagne you're not going for the
milk on there maybe [ __ ] on drink are
you certain everything make you [ __ ]
uh-huh I think I need a colonic so I'm
sure that you've been asked about the
Birdman incident in every interview that
you've had since put some respect on my
name became the meme of the year but I
want you need a post mortem of my own
okay when he stormed out of this studio
what was the immediate conversation that
you had with Angela Yee and envy what
was the first thing you guys talked
about do you remember well I know the
first thing I said why the [ __ ] would
you even come here if you don't want to
had a conversation and yes I've said why
would you sign the Birdman seeing his
history of not paying artists he said I
was messing up his money by saying that
so I thought he was coming to have the
conversation he came with all those
people but he was in the lobby and
Eminem lose yourself was playing now I
don't know if he had lose yourself in
his headphones and it was just loud or
lose yourself was on the radio I just
really remember
Eminem lose yourself playing and he was
just kind of pacing back and forth
getting in the zone getting ready to
lose it in the mall at what point did
you know that it was kind of flying off
the rails in a way that would make a big
wave on the internet I know right away
I'ma be honest which I didn't even think
it was gonna make a big wave on the
internet cuz I didn't see all those
little nuances like
unfolding it all the boys stuttering are
we finished our retards always done them
singing them storming out in a
single-file line
like they stormed out this single-file
line
[Music]
i'ma [ __ ] myself
I'm sharted I've started before and it
was spicy food it was you're making food
ate it the night before I was in
Columbia South Carolina and I just
dropped my girl off to her dog I was
trying to get back to my apartment and I
felt my stomach rumbling crazy I was
like okay my father he leave a little
bit of pressure when I fought it I [ __ ]
on myself and so and when it rumbles you
have to be careful absolutely I shot it
I don't some Genco gene to Julie's
apartment at some black dick oh geez
that is a long way you know you have
donkey of the day but we have our own
recurring segment here on hot ones I'll
explain that gram and what we do is we
do a deep dive on our guests Instagram
we pull interesting pictures what I'll
do is I'll show you the picture off your
Instagram if you could just tell me the
bigger story sound good
all right laptop please laptops first
one bottles for Charlemagne and
historically I've always landed drink
and I really liked the way he handled
his beef with Meek Mill like if somebody
challenges you on your writing skills
and challenges you on your art you
attack them with Josh we have to come
see a show I went to go see Utley so I
went backstage and took that picture
just to piss off some people and really
that pictures really does being Dickey
seriously when I was like let's be some
decades right now cuz he had all the
dishes going on with you know high mics
and we do change right now well mission
accomplished an accomplice absolutely
some of us go down in this pic con you
what that was last year house latching
the VMAs kind of a you got titties and
that pig completely pushes Low Energy
in that moment right Damian somehow go
Keanu Taylor was and I said I'm glad
that you're finally pushing her because
if you watch the lad rebel Club
interview I said why aren't you pushing
Teyana Taylor Kanekalon the star right
you got the look Tiana can sing our ass
off she can dance she's still young town
going like what 24 20 problem she liked
his personality had the personality like
why aren't you pushing Teyana Taylor
she's a star and he was proving to me
looks just what we want to do ah Thank
You failure
brought the floss you prepared hey Emma
which one is this how you doing so far I
feel like you're doing really well
you cool yourself man
are you possible well possible this
actually relates to the next question I
love how this always happens or always
seems to happen on hot one good because
you once replied to a first we feast
video the one with DJ Khaled's
restaurant in Miami by saying I love
finger lickin my fat ass watching this
video twice first thank you for the
retweet and for the repeat view second
if you were to invest in the food space
which road do you think you'd go down
would you go down the Jay Z nightclub
road would you go down the DJ Khaled
open up your own shop road would you go
down the Rick Ross wing stop checkers
franchise Road have you ever thought
about it and not only have I thought
about it I'm doing it I mean right now
I'm going to franchise thing but I don't
mind finger licking them because let's
see the guide it's sometimes hard to
tell would it be sort of an authentic
South Carolina barbecue spot would it be
a green juice shop have you ever thought
about what the concept might be I feel
like I could go home alone like I mean I
can feel like I can have a barbecue spot
that serve green juice and then you've
been around the game for a long time I
wonder if you've ever been to any of
those sort of lesser-known rap spots you
know Fat Joe he had that spot City
Island Express Oh dougie fresh he had
like a chicken and waffles a joint I go
there all the time and it never revealed
when outside of it it's got the graffiti
I know it would never be open ever and
fragile I would never go yes but not
because of jilted because I have a I
feel like the Bronx the Bronx yeah
excellent all of Florida had the
craziest people in the world
all right don't know
[Music]
all right that's a little bit tougher
Charlamagne huh
yes indeed happy was happening okay dawn
hot ones we're always trying to mix it
up with our guests and Breakfast Club is
kinda on the same wavelength
sometimes on one hand you kind of know
what to expect but then sometimes you'll
throw in these curve balls like Maury
Povich and dr. eyes and love it we want
to see them right now and that's what I
hope I'm not on is that sweating because
you've got a hot wings so what I want to
do is bounce some of the more offbeat
guests that you guys have had over the
last year or so and just kind of get
your reaction to them okay Martin
shkreli a frivolous prick straight
digital decade he's a troll like I don't
think he has the money that he says he
had any beginning to damned blue there
and on but he's not he's on Twitter
[ __ ] with people and always lying
about having new music and it's
analogies clean a clown Malcolm Gladwell
I love Malcolm Gladwell right to read
all my books I read on outliers I read
you know David and Goliath I read blank
already tipping point
so before I knew him I felt like I knew
it Lena Dunham love Leena done I've
always liked weird them I'm like Lena
Dunham two girls
I call her my problematic for instance
got it get on top of it whoo all right
are you ready to move on how you doing
I mean I got no choice get dull we
really have you're like kind of like
captured on the show so what is its long
this is the bomb beyond insanity hot
sauce mmm
[Music]
Charlotte min stop one tough way got a
respected though Charlemagne you're
going bone to bone on every single one
of these okay so I want to talk to you
about your book for a second
specifically creating one's own
opportunities is somebody who's deeply
ingrained in TV and radio and the
entertainment industry in general yeah
where do you think ones like whoo what
would you say is the number one [ __ ] up
people make when they're trying to break
through in this industry
number one [ __ ] up people make is that
they can't see opportunity unless it's a
paycheck attached to it I mean I started
off as an unpaid intern at z93 jams in
childhood South Carolina I mean prior to
that I was [ __ ] selling crack been
working at Taco Bell but it's like the
radio was just different for me because
it was actually the radio like you know
I'm from most one of psychology's listen
to radio all the time you know your
chant it was a big deal just to get a
shot up you know
I just loved it I was literally doing it
for free you know even with 1d which was
like my first real great break in the
game
her husband was like look we can't pay
you but we can give you a place to stay
now imagine if I didn't act like one of
these little entitled Millennials out
there been like nah I need to get some
bread bruh like me I'm like I cool
because I understand the opportunity I
know if I go on windy show and do what
I'm supposed to do I can write my own
ticket it's not that I don't even know
the [ __ ] sand I got my tongue is on
fire all right what's this so this is
mad dog 357 used to be our hottest hot
sauce it's our second hottest hot sauce
so you're the jeweler what does that
mean it means it's on you whatever
happens
[Music]
oh no and this went on feeling me
I think the bomb kind of numbs you out
of that that is a gardener part no
cleaning winds look at you shaman hmm
someone who watches you on TV or listen
to you on the radio knows that you're
really good at getting under people's
skin but those who follow you on twitter
and instagram know that people on the
Internet can get it the exact same way
can you give me the art of war when it
comes to teeing off on somebody on
Twitter I will definitely listen on
Twitter is a minute okay let me get you
on Twitter and social media period you
can't win
I've only seen one person beaten in poop
Tom Brady Tom Brady beat the goddamn
internet that Super Bowl night if you
remember correctly that Tom Brady was
getting nailed oh my god we was slow I
mean I like the painters family Cowboys
man we was slaughtering Tom Brady in his
fourth quarter should I turn right
around on five never seen a performer
like Tom Brady the only person I could
be doing it because I'm Jill respond
oh all the time I love me like my
straight like the barbs are on me right
now
Barb's hate me right now Bob's hate me
because they feel like I hate Nicki
Minaj which is intrumental I've always
liked Nicki but I don't like falesha she
does trying to get blog to pull things
and websites to pull stories and radio
station is it stops dancer and things
like [ __ ] Holly this is hip-hop like
you're not exempt from anything that's
being done in the culture you're not
existent getting talked about in the
culture so I wanted her to respond
constant hip-hop [ __ ] crystal nickel
guru or the hustle switcher which
celebrities fanbase has the most vicious
Twitter onslaught who are the toughest
is it the Beehive is the bar is that the
Navy is to beehive and it's not even
close
The Beehive is destroy career we arm
Keri Hilson on a long time I'm gonna
tell you who the worst to not on the
level of the be I could they don't have
no impact the air is cricket they talk
so much [ __ ] online but don't buy her
out if y'all [ __ ] was an active
lying around is y'all are talking [ __ ]
to people she'd be poppin all right
Charlemagne how you doing my man
intelligence uh I think we got all those
nothing on it no there is there is
Charlemagne's but it's tradition around
here put a little extra dab on the last
one you don't have to if you don't want
to know what do you call it dad just a
little bit I'm careful be careful so
that's good don't you go there you go
cheers cheers Cheers on me
[Music]
keep it in just a little bit taking out
that water it's all right we got to swap
it okay oh-oh-oh-oh not an easy one
Charlemagne not an easy one we're gonna
piss yourself on dr. Oz I don't think
you have to worry about shorty I don't
mind you may have really no need to ever
do that unless you doing the show all
right
now that we're dying on Blairs Megadeth
sauce with liquid rage I have one more
question for you you know I know that
there's no love lost between hot 97 and
power 105 and now that the hot sauce is
digging deep India finding that bottom
of your soul right now I do wonder if
you had to give a compliment
say the nicest thing that you possibly
could about Rosenberg and Ebro what
would that nice thing be if USA flex the
end flexing the legend a thunder tune
you grew up in hip hop and you say to
Funkmaster Flex's a legend you just hate
what tell me another two of you
acknowledgement can't even think of
nothing good to say come on try
Rutherford called you the dumb I might
be to him mmm I feel like the goddamn
devil right now because I am burning oh
you might be burning up but you know
what Charlotte man you made it through
are you screaming you ate the wings down
to the bone you took out at least two or
three pictures of water but I loved it I
respect it this camera this camera or
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
diarrhea it feels like something
something bad is about to happen
well yeah black privilege opportunity
comes to those who created April 18th
you can pre-order now at wherever you
buy both Amazon more than over level and
Lister Breakfast Club everyone in on
common sense every Friday at 11:30 on
mtv2 it's always the show we have to
apologize for shop
thing though what I signed up for hey
what's going on hot ones fans if you
like the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you like the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend